look like his ankle
might have just turned it a little bit
contest second offensive glass each and
every time top floor not that triple
that was a good reversal there by
Carmelo generally was that his best with
a good job transition defense there by
the Warriors still a one-man fast break
though blood on floor I could read
protection for the Thunder now when you
don't have Steven Adams out there
[Applause]
you
Tim Duncan out here into the glass or is
this Russell Westbrook even though you
she had Westbrook there on to
that was a matchup that posed as I'm
sure we're looking forward to coming
into this game Westbrook is stealing it
here she swore Dan is a sister up to
this has to be on this team another
great move by
went off to a hot start here then it
wasn't attractive
it's a there
[Music]
that you the James put my thumb out and
asked if I could have a ride in that
Ferrari what he moved here by Westbrook
in the open court makka really looking
for help
on an island all by yourself kim our
wedding there for Mona did you see girl
ready 31 points given up here in this
first quarter this Jeff Perry was
veterans
[Applause]
[Music]
where to
to be relentless
are you kidding me
Russell Westbrook
a show here in this first quarter with
karate bullies is weigh-in able to get
that finish high it gives you and
understand why this guy might end up
being the Defensive Player of the Year
see he is meant to richly and he's still
giving you the business on the other
hand Western Conference Finals or give
sue the finals
then I think he stays but if they give a
first round exit hole
on the big side by Paul woods right
there
[Applause]
just put so much pressure off of your
defense the wings to your point
[Applause]
you'll go two for two right now
especially with this 18 point lead and
yet
maybe 17 that they just have not had any
resistance as well
- so what right here
[Music]
he knew he might not finish that one but
he was able to gather some corners
to be their first CD top-up the
hesitation there by Paul George Oh boys
see notice how he doesn't kick you
notice that right you see how straight
up straight down
[Music]
[Applause]
the details d better oh another
and deflection by Paul George right into
the grill of Kay dude gets a steal but
here just the nice little step back into
that trip line again good defense by
Durant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here just to finish over Pachulia Zaza
welcome to your Kodak moment
[Music]
[ __ ] Wilhelm
[Music]
pgdavis would that be a lot of shoes
right now
I mean the occasion without a shot that
boy Vidal was wearing a shooter before
yes sounds with a cloud